au musée des flonflons ce sont eux deux
enfants amis inséparables un peu
amoureux qui subit ces décisions des
grands à l'origine un album death byetta
auteurs jeunesse j'ai l'impression ça
c'est pas parce qu'on fait de l'art du
théâtre jeune public ne peut pas parler
de sujets graves
c'est un c'est un livre qui en parle
dans ce cas c'est une histoire qui parle
de ces sujets là de la guerre la
séparation qui on parle aussi beaucoup
de joie et espoir voilà c'est malgré un
sujet un peu difficile c'est pour moi
c'est un spectacle noir flonflons et
musette dure une trentaine de minutes où
les personnages sont des petits doudous
l'apa c'est sûr que nos questions
l'intrication en fait l'enfant peut
identifier l'objet
assez assez facilement et le fait que ce
soit des doudous les lapins ça sert un
choix de l'auteur et du byetta je crois
que sa distance aussi la distance aussi
les propos au cercle serait pas vraiment
des enfants voient ce sens que ça ça
reste des animaux qui ont des
comportements des comportements
[Musique]
un seul en scène délicat à découvrir dès
l'âge de 4 ans un moment plein de
tendresse